okay like a versus why did I edit this
report that's weird I don't know it's
like I forgot about it really is a
forgotten blog found it though hey guys
so Casey just found some really old
footage of us back from 2012 before we
really made things official and before
he even met Isaac that was like a whole
lifetime ago man our lives are so
different back then
this footage here it was the very first
trip that we ever took and it's funny
because we didn't even know where this
relationship was going cuz it was still
in that like oh this is kind of a flame
like who knows if this is even gonna go
anywhere but for some reason we decided
to take a trip down to Mexico and he met
some family members and he got pretty
serious pretty fast even though we were
trying to make it seriously was this
trip tech notice to be very serious like
meet your family car the family what
goodness we're just gonna do it and it's
funny now like that you found this
footage and we can see how our dynamic
was back then because that was so camera
shy like so so camera shy yeah so are
you
and then so back then he had this GoPro
right and like I hated this but you used
to always put the camera so close to my
face it's a girl cuz it's a wide lens
and it catches everything whatever but
still it just was so intimidating having
a freaking camera like this close to me
so I'm like no I hate it so I'm really
curious to see what you actually
captured cuz I do remember back then
inking like oh my god get that camera
away from my face
[Music]
we are right before the border where the
horn that don't they like a braces this
is that we're saying where you got my
braces forget it
I have been waxed your hair braces I was
so shy see I'm like get the camera out
of my face
you know how Isaac right now with his
braces is his lips kind of tucked behind
the bracket I was happening to me my
upper lips look like so much skinnier
but it looked so uncomfortable
really I used to talk like this to my
mom I was like Josh Dalton's talk
skeleton stuff like this analyst I'm
weird - it's okay so are we together
telling you right now brush across
America NASA is testing hurry oh I think
this is my first exposure to light yeah
hidden like and I just met you too so it
wasn't like I was hanging around with
Mexican people all the times I'd even
know what Mexican American culture was
much less than Mexico culture you know
so I was like just drop me into you find
out anything right after this is when we
planned New York together if we were
just started planning trips back to back
this is the beginning of our part of our
vacation trip taking yeah oh you're so
shy we're like let's get on camera then
they're right afterwards like always the
cameras there
[Music]
like a different person you do - that's
what you used to be more like you had
more of a chip on your shoulder back
then
yeah I mean your little faux hawk yeah
and my earrings in - oh yeah I'd be hard
you know hard with studs
hang em was like a baby I look more
Mexican - there's like darker areas
around my face I like dark in like the
complexion is like darker how do you
become less Mexican over the years
[Music]
doesn't count right now I pointed it out
[Music]
I remember my ABS because by then like
you know we were we were dating already
but it wasn't anything serious event
hey so maybe you guys shouldn't stay in
the same room cuz it's just not very
ladylike so I'm like my god yeah okay
fine we won't stay in the same room in
the same no we did it
Larry yeah we actually slept in separate
rooms I remember that because I remember
she had a problem with it
so I'm like okay I mean it's your house
I'll respect your rules that's fine
married I know amen
oh you look so little oh you run got the
camera my first time eating Mexican
seafood I think oh really
yeah I saw your light at that time I
didn't know Mexicans a seafood one
reason I never equated that's all my
daddy
yeah no over one favorite cuisine in the
world
[Music]
first time drinking yeah I just didn't
know anything I thought I opened your
eyes my Mexican my Mexican cuisine
knowledge was tex-mex oh yeah and then
Taco Bell very fine Mexico you know
crazy those since getting with you I
stopped being a Mexican
I don't tap into my Mexican culture
anymore actually feel very disconnected
from my own culture nice to speak
Spanish all the time I was immersed in
Mexican culture and now I don't have it
at all in my day-to-day life and I can't
miss it sometime and it kind of gets me
sad because I'm like see would happen
like I kind of feel like I lost a part
of myself so watching this vlog now and
seeing how we're in Mexico kind of
missed the slice of Mexican culture that
that Tiffany had this you were very had
such a heavy accent I couldn't enunciate
my tongue was lazy lazy was it weird
having an Asian guy walk with you in
Mexico you know it's I had never
experienced that like uncomfortableness
with the person I'm with because of
their race like I've never experienced
that and I did with you and it was weird
cuz I'm like whoa this feels weird I
feel like something's at a place but why
does it feel that way I shouldn't feel
that way but it does that's why I
remember when you asked me do we look
good together and I was like honestly no
I didn't realize how how much is stood
out that we were different race until it
was like in front of my face walking
around Mexico with you and getting the
stairs that's when I started feeling
like wow this is kind of weird like this
a little bit faster without your comfort
zone it was enough to stand out to me
then it'll obviously did whether we need
a certain degree but not enough to be
like I can't be with you I can't put up
with this you know it wasn't like that
like that life-changing
[Music]
yeah I remember going to this beach and
then I remember we ran into some
stranger's and then they were like eh
it's the no of U of T no like is that
your boyfriend the Chinese guy I'm like
yeah like almost every stranger that I
mean I said Jackie Chan Oh Mike is like
the only thing they know I know I'm like
oh yeah I'm his nephew
found that dead jellyfish swim up on the
shore and then we found him in the rocks
what was I taking so many photos why was
my so intrigued for this dead jellyfish
we were all fascinated by a jellyfish I
was like the highlight of our Beach our
time at the beach and I remember my my
aunt started scooping up yeah see she's
scooping it up right now
and we were all scared because we wanted
to play with it for some weird reason
but we were also scared that we were
gonna get stung and I remember we were
trying to take a photo with it and then
Jenni was like you google it I don't
want to get stung can you google it
[Music]
yeah oh my god
see you're that voice doing my face no
wonder when you when we spoke on the
phone for the first time all that km us
I think you're like Hello like Burger
King look said V tell them you feel mean
he'll deliver to your house so Wednesday
your favorite lobster food person every
anywhere I go the best things were
probably food like I remember when we
saw that on the side of the road I was
like all this pullover or let's okay see
how they do on and then I was just so
excited to show you
humming through the coconut yeah that
thing was oh it made me not care about
the coconut think is that like the
coconut feel of flash here and then you
were trying to like whatever father was
[Music]
see you gringo fight
[Music]
you can't roll your arm I'm always gonna
have an accent I'm a rasp a doe respeto
but yeah you were trying to sell me on
the vowel and and I was like that
doesn't sound amazing at all that sounds
disgusting
anyway I didn't tell you though I don't
know like I don't want that coconuts
though I know what coconuts are that
looks flash it was that risk let's do
some of that then you come over with a
bottle and I'm like oh that's the good
stuff right there that's so good
okay the fact that you're dating this
new guy so you're already kind of shy
around him and then you're bringing him
around your family so that adds like
another level of like insecurity and
then there's a camera in front of your
face so that's double that of insecurity
so I I sounded so secure and shy and
like kind of like I'm trying to keep my
cool right now but I'm really really
really shy
dang that's so funny seeing the dynamic
together yeah how shy we were we didn't
know each other that well so like even
like how like we banter was like we're
innocent yeah look more innocent now
there's like too much history there
where it's like any little things I
could get triggered yeah we get your guy
by the littlest things and that's
marriage for you man that's so funny
honestly going through the splitter
jumping like there's so many moments in
here where I'm like if that was done
today that would benefit now we've been
a fight that would have been a fight
like but because it was so new it was
just like Oh funny Alice like this is us
going back across the border we decided
to walk the border okay
hurry back
so shy has such a baby face seeing I was
22 there you were a baby you wanted to
is a baby to me now for sure but it
looks like we were 17 like though you
were acting our mannerisms and
everything it just seemed like we were
way younger than we were sure especially
since I've braces English did you know
you're gonna marry that girl if you
could say one thing advice or whatever
it is to that Tiffany what would because
man I have so many things to say to that
oh man
maybe tell him just be completely honest
man that's it just be honest that would
avoid so many things true so much I was
frightened too much I feel like listen
you can be honest with that girl she'll
accept you don't worry just don't like
and then to tell that Tiffany I would
have told her oh I would have told her
what I'm learning right now which is hey
um you know that voice inside your head
that's not very nice just remember that
it needs to be nicer just be kinder and
inside your own head and by doing that
you won't be so insecure you'll find the
confidence once you find that love
within yourself what would you have said
to that Kasey the world is only as rough
as you make it out to be and be happy
for that Tiffany I would say
to be forgiving she wasn't very
forgiving huh
No till this day she's not very good to
be a little more forgiving and in order
to heal and get past all the lows you
must make amends with it yes in order to
move forward because you'll never move
forward until you do that that's the
hard part
well yeah that's pretty cool man almost
seven years thanks for watching us
relive our very first trip together
almost seven years ago back when we were
completely different people and marriage
where you met Isaak
[Music]